as you'll know spain under francisco
franco was neutral in the second world
war despite this it obviously had a
preference for the axis as well as
ideological sympathies towards the
regimes in italy and germany
given franco's preference this raises a
question after the fall of the axis why
didn't the allies get rid of franco as
well
so towards the end of the war franco
could tell which way the wind was
blowing and knew that the axis wasn't
going to win
as such he began to make friendly
overtures towards the allies
now he wasn't going to join the war on
the ally side or anything because one
spain was still recovering from the
civil war and two
germany was still in control of the
south of france until late 1944 and so
could have launched punitive actions
against spain
although after the fall of germany the
spanish government did consider
declaring war in japan to improve
relations with the allies
after the war was over and europe was
divided franco was pretty nervous about
his position
and with fairly good reason the ussr
demanded that franco be ousted first by
economic embargo and if that failed then
via military action
now the soviet union made these demands
because for them it was a win-win
if the allies removed franco then there
would be a fair shot that a communist
government could be installed in spain
and if franco stayed well then the west
wouldn't be able to criticize the ussr's
occupation and treatment of any eastern
european nations
since at that point it would be
hypocritical the western powers refused
to do this because they couldn't justify
another war to their people in a rough
country for fighting against a country
that hadn't really done much to oppose
them
so franco's main worry after the war was
france who disliked him for three
reasons
first he existed and openly coveted
french lands in africa
second france had recently been invaded
by a neighboring fascist country and it
really wanted to make sure that that
could never happen again
and third franco's government killed a
famous member of the french resistance
in late 1946 which outraged the french
public who demanded that franco be
removed by force
now franco had been busy for the past
few years making friends with the other
major western allies which he used to
his advantage he was particularly nice
to the british and had made arrangements
to hand over germans for trial to them
and also he promoted nonphalanges to
government to assure the british that
his regime could change
the americans didn't really buy it but
britain wanted a stable spain especially
one that wasn't going to invade
gibraltar
and thus britain made it clear that they
would oppose any french intervention
there
as such the french turned to the
americans to ask franco which they
agreed to do by forging a military coup
against him and replacing him with a
democratic government however britain
again refused to back this plan and
strongly argued against it
britain was concerned that spain would
enter into another second bloody civil
war and at the end of it there could be
a communist government in madrid
and in the end the americans decided not
to go ahead with it this was because
truman felt that western unity in the
face of communism was much more
important than removing franco and
in the end franco's gamble of simply
waiting paid off the allies soon turned
their attention to the east in combating
the spread of communism
something that franco could help with i
hope you enjoyed this episode and thank
you for watching with a special thanks
to my patrons
james bissonette kelly moneymaker
anthony beckett
the pastry section danny maloney rob
waterhouse
mo aaron the white james castaneda
jordan longley
jerry lamdin marcus asner gustav swan
john bailey
colin castleman rasheed ali spinning
three plates fielder oink oink izzy
david silverman maggie paxkowski winston
k wood
spencer lightfoot robert wetzel
fortunate calf lexi schwinn
sky chappelle and marvin cassell